أخبر ابنته المراهقة أنه سيقودها
إلى المدرسة
بدلاً من ذلك ، فسافر بالسيارة إلى سفارة كوريا الجنوبية
وطلب اللجوء.
أخبرتها أن تأتي مع والدتها وأبيها لتجد
الحرية
، لقد صدمت ثم قالت حسنًا ،
هذا كل ما قالت
إنه كان يعمل سفير كوريا الشمالية
إلى الكويت حتى انشقاقه في سبتمبر
2019.
جزء من النخبة في كوريا الشمالية ،
دبلوماسي متميز
من بلد يصف نفسه بأنه
فردوس اشتراكي ، كان بمثابة حطام للحياة وكانت
زوجته
يائسة لإنقاذ ابنتهما
في أول مقابلة لهما في شارع يكشف
كم كان القرار مؤلمًا جعل
صوته يتشقق عندما يفكر في
والدته البالغة من العمر 83 عامًا والدا زوجته المسنين
وإخوته جميعًا في
بيونغ يانغ ،
أريد فقط أن أراهم يعيشون طويلاً ، أي
فكرة عن عقابهم على
ما فعلت  فقط يؤذي قلبي ،
كوريا الشمالية في عهد كيم جونغ أون كانت لديها
سياسة معاقبة عائلات
المنشقين
، رادعًا لأولئك الذين يريدون
الفرار والشعور بالذنب مدى الحياة
لأولئك الذين يفرون من شارع سا  نعم ، لقد شاهد
قمة 2018 بين
الرئيس الأمريكي آنذاك دونالد
ترامب وكيم جونغ أون أثناء وجوده في الكويت
كدبلوماسي اعتقدت أن هذه قد تكون صورة
سياسية لا يمكننا التراجع عن
نزع السلاح النووي ولا يمكن لكيم جونغ أون
نزع السلاح النووي في
كوريا الشمالية  ترتبط الطاقة النووية
ارتباطًا مباشرًا باستقرار النظام ،
ولا أستطيع أن أتخيل أنهم ألغوا مرحباً
جوزيف
فيما يتعلق بنصيحة الرئيس جو بايدن
شارع
معارضين مستشهدين بخبرة بايدن الطويلة في السياسة الخارجية ،
لكنه يعتقد أن كوريا الشمالية
ستفكر فقط في الحد من الأسلحة النووية
وليس  التخلي عنها بالكامل
مع قبولها كدولة نووية ،
ما الذي يريده كيم جونغ أون من
الرئيس بايدن ،
أعتقد أنه يريد منا أن
نفرض عقوبات على خطوة لا تعتقد أنه
يجب أن تحدث ، كما يريد
أن تكون قضية حقوق الإنسان  جزء مهم من
سياسة بايدن تجاه كوريا الشمالية ،
فهو يرى أن اتفاق بايدن النووي السابق
مع إيران يمثل علامة على الأمل في التعامل
مع كوريا الشمالية ،
لكنه يقدم حقيقة واقعة.  إن
كوريا الشمالية ستكون
أصعب من إيران باولا هانكوكس سي إن إن سول